junker town is Duncan town circuit town
dirty crazy harsh chaotic unforgiving
grungy organic lawless carnage beautiful
loss a comic relief chunker town is the
best thing ever
three words
[Music]
Shanker town is a really important area
in overwatch after the omnis the
australian government was trying to make
peace with the omnicons in australia and
so if they allow them to sort of have
the land around the australian omnium
unfortunately that would displace the
solar farmers and other people who are
living out there which included one
Maiko Rutledge you had this group that
was sort of misplaced and then fought
back against the omnium and not only
fought back but did it in whatever
ragtag way they could that ultimately
resulted in the detonation of the omnium
and what they've done is they've built
on top of the wreckage and what we're
seeing now is that town nowadays Jonker
town is run by a lady called the queen
she has a really interesting backstory
there is a place called the scrap yard
where they watch gladiatorial combat of
people driving max people fighting each
other people fighting omnec and that is
where the Queen came from she was a
really charismatic and skilled fighter
the Queen is the boss and all the
Junkers have to be very cautious about
what they do in terms of the Queen
why did junk rat and road hog go on that
worldwide ice-free there's two things
that solve every problem money and
explosives they wanted to try and buy
their way into the Queen's good graces
you can see a lot of that as we escort
the payload which has all the treasures
that they've collected across their
journeys and also has a little special
surprise for the people who kick them
out
once we saw junker town and we knew junk
rat and road hog as characters we knew
that we had to relay that in the sounds
so he'll find a lot of dirty grungy
things that sound loose and broken we
used a lot of levers and pulleys and
chains and just old things that are
rusty that you can get tetanus from we
went up to this really old ghost town
and it was so silent there that we were
able to get all these little intricate
sounds like even flies landing on the
microphone you're able to hear there's
this really cool hand crank that we
pitched down a little bit and then some
chain pulleys that go with it and that's
the main basis of the payload that
you'll hear as it moves through the
streets
so in junker Town is obviously a escort
map and there are some interesting new
wrinkles to the formula that we throw on
this map we start in the outskirts of
junker town at Road hogs farm there's a
lot of sheet metal and things plastered
on the walls to make it feel a little
warm I feel like the abandoned farm is
kind of a nice grounded area of the map
and as you move through this level you
slowly get into this kind of more sci-fi
high fantasy parts of the level the next
section I think is my favorite section
which is junker town proper you get to
see what life is like in junker town
they've got their shops and they've got
their tattoos and they've got their car
mechanic shops
you've got your wacky bar that's
actually in the sewer pipe which just
makes you ask a lot of questions and
then finally we get to the scrapyard
where the great battles happen powerful
champions have come through the ranks
and have seized power and fame and glory
in junker town and it's gonna create a
lot of interesting scenarios
you've got the turbine which is the big
fan that's spinning above and so players
can stand on this thing while it rotates
you don't put turns on top of it but
you've also got a pass through that sort
of shortcuts either from the attacker
straight to the final point or from the
defenders to the earlier choke in the
space and we feel like this is gonna add
a really interesting gameplay dynamic we
didn't want junker ten to just be this
hopeless desolate impossible place to
survive so we really tried to fulfill
that post-apocalyptic fantasy but also
have a certain element to it were you
like oh you know what I would actually
eat at that restaurant we get so much
opportunity to focus the story on
overwatch and Kalin but we don't get a
lot of opportunity to explore some of
these other groups and I hope that
junker Town is the tip of the iceberg
for what's more to come for chunk rat
road hog the Queen and the Junkers as a
whole
[Music]
dad
you